Dann kommen wir vom Flug Richtung Landung.
Zu der Landung an ist es wichtig, dass wir vorgängig geschaut haben, was wir für einen Lande wollten fliegen.
Ist es ein Rechts- oder ein Links-Wolken?
Und vor allem ist es wichtig, dass wir alle die gleichen Regeln befolgen.
Weil in diesem Bereich des Fluges sind wir nicht mehr weit weg vom Boden.
Das heisst, wir haben keine Zeit mehr oder wenig Zeit zum Reagieren.
Haben wir 1000 Meter über dem Grund, haben wir, wenn jemand etwas nicht so macht wie es sollte,
relativ lange Zeit zum Reagieren und die Situation einschätzen.
Beim Landen geht alles ein bisschen schneller, weil der Boden einfach nahe ist.
Darum muss der Grundsatz sein, dass wir uns alle an die Landewolken halten
und so garantieren können, dass wir sehen, was der andere, der Vorgänger, macht.
Die Landewolke sieht so aus, dass wir uns für einen Links- oder Rechts-Wolken entscheiden
und nachher zu den Positionskreisen, zu unseren Abbaukreisen kommen,
wo wir unsere Höhe abbauen.
Um für eine saubere Landewolke zu beginnen, ist es wichtig, dass wir in die Drehrichtung kreisen,
wo wir die Landewolke machen.
Machen wir einen Rechts-Wolken, sind es ein Rechts-Kreis.
Machen wir einen Links-Wolken, sind es ein Links-Kreis.
Dann gehen wir auf eine Höhe, die Landewolke, die gesund ist.
Und diese gesunde Höhe, das lernt ihr einschätzen nach ein, zwei, drei Landungen.
Ich habe das schon relativ gut im Griff.
Indem ihr auch immer visuell wieder den Punkt anschaut, merkt ihr,
aha, jetzt bin ich noch so hoch.
Und im Grundsatz kommt es lieber zu hoch, richtig landen,
als zu tief, weil Höhe verschafft wieder Zeit.
Tief verursacht Stress.
Wenn ihr losfliegt von der Positionskreisrichtung gegen Anflug,
dann nehmt auch keine visuellen Sachen,
wie zum Beispiel, ich bin immer auf Baumhöhe oder bin immer auf dieser Haushalthöhe
richtig gegen Anflug geflogen.
Das kann variieren, je nach Luftmasse, wo ihr euch befindet,
muss das überhaupt nicht gleich sein.
Es ändert auch komplett, wenn ihr Wind im Spiel habt.
Darum ist es wichtig, hier ein Gespür zu entwickeln.
Ihr traut euch darauf, es hat noch jeder nach zwei, drei, vier Flügen.
Die anderen brauchen ein bisschen mehr.
Aber darum sind ihr in Begleitung vom Fluglehrer mit dem Funk,
wo ich euch schön Anweisungen geben kann,
dass ihr das zuerst ein bisschen ferngesteuert macht
und nach gewissen Anzahl Flüge selbstständig machen könnt.
Gegenanflug, Queranflug, Endanflug.
Wenn wir merken, im Gegenanflug sind wir deutlich zu hoch,
dann können wir wunderbar in den Queranflug gehen
und den Queranflug können wir auch verlängern.
Wenn wir Platz haben, gehen wir weit, weit nach vorne und machen einen Bogen.
Wenn wir zu kurz sind, dann merken wir, wir sind nicht immer so viel höher.
Dann können wir das Ganze auch verkürzen, wie es hier dargestellt ist.
Oder wir können den Queranflug auch mit S x-fach wiederholen.
Und der S muss immer richtig Punkte folgen.
Und das Gute bei diesen S ist, wir können zu jedem Zeitpunkt
den Queranflug verlassen und in den Endanflug gehen, wenn wir sehen, es passt.
Nachher der Endanflug.
Der Endanflug sollte gerade erfolgen.
Wir können selbstverständlich eine leichte Korrektur machen,
wenn der Wind etwas seitlich kommt.
Aber schlussendlich wichtig, dass wir gerade auf den Landepunkt zufliegen.
Wenn wir merken, wir sind viel zu hoch, gibt es verschiedene Varianten.
Wir können zum Beispiel uns gross machen.
Das heisst, der Pilot unter dem Schirm macht relativ viel Widerstand.
Und ob wir kompakt sitzen, dann gleiten wir gut, haben wir wenig Widerstand.
Oder wir machen uns gross.
Das heisst, wir setzen uns auf dem Gurtzug,
schauen, dass unser Fahrwerk, nämlich die Beine, bereits bereit sind.
Und dann machen wir viel Widerstand und haben ein schlechtes Gleiten.
Das heisst, dann können wir die Höhe effizient abbauen.
Und so kommen wir dann auf den Landepunkt zu.
Eine andere Variante wäre, ganz leichte S zu fliegen.
Das ist auch erlaubt.
Oder, wenn wir später dazukommen, mit kleinen Öhrchen landen.
Dass wir die Öhrchen nehmen, der Gleitschirm wird einfach kleiner,
hat mehr Sinken.
Und auch so hat man dann eine bessere Erfolgschance,
auf den Punkt zu landen.
An der Briefung übrigens ist das ein 30-Meter-Kreis,
den ihr treffen müsst, in den Kreis hinein.
Und dann habt ihr die Landung super und gut bestanden.
Wichtig noch, wenn ihr die kleinen Ohren macht,
müsst ihr euch bewusst sein, ihr habt die Arme so,
dass ihr nicht mehr gross steuern könnt.
Ihr könnt mit Gewichten ausrichten,
aber eure Manövrierfähigkeit ist eingeschränkt,
dass man das beachtet.
Also lieber halt auch mal etwas zu weit landen,
als etwas unüberlegt zu machen oder im Stress zu machen.
Das ist meistens nicht gut.
Dann gibt es ja noch Situationen,
wo man die Landung vielleicht etwas anders bekommt,
als wir gedacht haben.
Zum Beispiel, jetzt sind wir landen wollten angeflogen,
wir haben vorne den Windsack angeschaut,
da stand es immer schön so,
dass wir eigentlich mit dem Endanflug gegen den Wind landen sollten,
wie wir es ja normal machen.
Jetzt haben wir halt doch blöderweise plötzlich Rückenwind,
weil der Wind einfach gewechselt hat.
Das ist kein Drama, es ist wichtig,
dass wir die Landung wollten durchziehen,
weil wir haben uns entschieden für diese Landung wollten
und dann landen wir halt mit Rückenwind.
Mit Rückenwind heisst das,
wir haben mehr Geschwindigkeit im Endanflug.
Das heisst, wir müssen einfach schneller,
effektiver durchbremsen,
als wir das beim normalen Landen gewohnt sind.
Beim normalen Landen gegen den Wind
können wir relativ gemütlich durchbremsen,
bis unter das Füdle und unten bleiben
und beim Rückenwindlanden müssen wir ein bisschen höher
und wirklich entschieden runterbremsen,
dass wir ein Momentum aufbauen,
in dem der Schirm sich aufstellt
und genau in diesem Zeitpunkt am Boden ist.
Selbst dann kann man bei Rückenwind
schöne Landungen machen,
die auf die Beine gehen.
Rückenwindlandung ist also kein Drama,
sondern auch ein Punkt,
den man gut mal üben kann.
Wir reden hier natürlich nicht von 30 km Rückenwind,
sondern von 5 bis 10 km Wind,
den man managen könnte.
Jetzt kann es ja auch sein,
dass wir eine Hanglandung machen müssen.
Das kann auch sein,
dass z.B. ein Landeplatz gesperrt ist.
Wir haben keine andere Möglichkeit.
Die Hanglandung ist wichtig,
dass wir nicht richtig, wenn wir hier den Hang haben,
dass wir nicht einfach auf den Hang zufliegen,
weil sonst haben wir die Hangneigung,
die uns ziemlich eine Strichdurchrechnung macht
beim Ausfliegen,
sondern wir müssen parallel zum Hang landen.
Dann können wir genau das gleiche Landen machen,
parallel zum Hang aufsetzen,
dann geht das tiptop.
Jetzt kann es ja auch sein,
dass wir den Landeplatz verpasst haben
und auf einem Parkplatz landen können,
wo Autos stehen.
Oder wir haben einen Zaun im Weg,
den wir vorher nicht gesehen haben.
Auf dem Landeplatz hat der Bauer
noch ein paar Kühe auf die Wiese gestellt
und einen stabilen Zaun angestellt.
Den Zaun haben wir jetzt einfach nicht gesehen
und gehen voll im Flug darauf zu.
Jetzt kann man sagen,
gut, jetzt kann man auch scheisse machen,
Kollusion kann man nicht verhindern,
aber man kann doch immerhin noch Energie anbauen.
Das kann man auch machen,
indem man einfach
genau gleich über dem Land
voll durchbremst.
Damit die Energie weg ist,
ist es ein Unterschied,
ob wir mit 30 kmh in einen Zaun fliegen
oder nur mit 5 kmh oder sogar 0 kmh.
Dann können wir nämlich auf dem Zaun landen.
Darum bei einer Kollusion
denkt daran, Energie abzubauen
und nicht einfach da oben bleiben
und schreien, da nützt nichts.
Da nützt nur, dass die Leute schauen
und noch mehr Zuschauer haben
in dieser peinlichen Situation.
Falsch gemacht,
den Landeplatz erreicht ihr nicht mehr
und auf dem Weg zum Landeplatz
hat es nur noch Bäume.
Dann ist vielleicht eine Baumlandung
das Schlimmste, was ihr machen könnt,
bevor ihr irgendwo Richtung Felswand geht
oder wo es noch blöder ist zum Landen.
Eine Baumlandung, wenn ihr es schon könnt,
bevorzugen nehmen den Nadelbaum.
Der hält schön.
Ihr könnt euch gut an den Ästen halten,
wo ihr runter landet
und so, wichtig, schöner hineinfliegen.
Auch hier wieder Energie abbauen
durch die Dürrenbremse
und mit den Armen den Kopf schützen
vor diesen Ästen.
Wichtig, es gibt
gute Dokumentationen über Baumrettungen.
Der Gleitschimpilot,
der in die Bäume fliegt,
ist meistens sehr sicher,
wie er sehr viele Leinen reinkommt.
Das gilt auch, wenn ihr einen Notschirmabgang
über einen Wald hättet.
Da ist sehr viel Stoff, sehr viele Leinen
und die verfangen sich in Ästen.
Es gibt sehr wenige Fälle,
bei denen der Pilot durch die Bäume
bis zum Boden gekommen ist.
Meistens bleibt er hängen
und dann ist man grundsätzlich sicher.
Die meisten Unfälle, die daraus resultieren,
sind, weil die Leute im Schock,
was meistens ein Schock ganz klar ist,
eine Notsituation ist,
sich selbst befreien wollen
und dann abstürzen.
Weil sie z.B. in einem steilen Gelände
auf einem Baum sitzen
und so seitlich zum Gelände schauen
und sehen, dass es nur 2 Meter ist.
Und wenn man sich dann vom Gurtzug löst
und abstürzt,
sind 15 Meter absolut verheerend.
Wichtig, wenn das passiert,
ist grundsätzlich mal Ruhe angesagt.
Ruhe, Ruhe, Ruhe.
Und dann sich Zeit geben
und sagen, gut,
jetzt müssen wir die Situation analysieren.
Am schlauesten, wenn ihr euch
in zivilisierter Gegend befindet,
ist sowieso die Bergrettung zu informieren,
die Rega zu informieren.
Ziemlich sicher hat auch jemand gesehen
den Absturz und vielleicht sogar schon gemeldet.
Wir sind die froh,
dass ihr wisst, wo ihr seid,
ob es euch gut geht
und ob ihr Hilfe benötigt.
Und Hilfe benötigt in meiner Ansicht
immer dann, wenn ihr merkt,
ihr seid auf einem Baum
und er ist auch höher als 1-2 Meter.
Dann kommt die Bergrettung,
die kann euch damit auch helfen.
Auch mit dem Schirmbergen ist es viel einfacher
als einen Sturz zu riskieren,
wo man, wie vorhin gesagt,
doch hoch abstürzen kann.
Also sprich, informieren die Leute,
was los ist und
auf die Hilfe warten.
Es braucht manchmal Geduld.
In unseren Gegenden haben wir
einen sehr schönen Partner
mit der Rega, die sehr schnell sind
und dementsprechend auch
die Rettung sehr schnell eingeleitet werden kann.
Eine andere Landessituation,
die hoffentlich nie zutrifft,
darum ist sie auch hier so markiert,
ist die Wasserlandung.
Wasserlandung muss man vermeiden,
weil ein stehendes Gewässer
im Winter sehr sehr kalt werden kann
und man verheddert sich sehr schnell
in Leinen und durch
und kann sich so unfähig machen
zum Schwimmen.
Viel schlimmer ist es noch,
wenn es im Fluss ist.
Im Fluss treibt es,
da ist es ziemlich unkontrollierbar,
ob man überhaupt rauskommt.
Es kann dort, wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt,
einfach möglichst früh,
wenn ihr seht, dass ihr ins Wasser geht,
die Schnallen vom Gurtzug aufmachen,
damit man sofort weg von der Ausrüstung fliegen kann.
Wichtig ist aber Gumpen nie,
bevor ihr das Wasser pariert,
aus dem Gurtzug heraus.
Weil in den Schockmoment,
im Adrenalin, wo ihr seid,
habt ihr nicht im Griff,
seid ihr jetzt 5 Meter über dem Wasserspiegel
und gumpet oder seid ihr auf 20 Meter
und das kann auch wieder sehr starke Folgen haben,
wenn ihr das falsch einschätzen würdet.
Darum eine Wasserlandung
grundsätzlich vermeiden,
das heisst für mich,
ich gehe nicht irgendwelche Manöver trainieren,
über Wasser, über Fluss,
es sei denn, es ist in einem begleitenden Training,
wie in einem Sicherheitstraining,
wo immer ein Böden draussen bereit ist,
wo man das genau nutzt,
die Wasserflächen,
weil die Wasserflächen sind schön,
wir haben keine Hindernisse.
Wenn ich aber einfach so fliegen gehe,
dann meide ich Wasserflächen,
ich meide Flüsse und ich meide See.
Wenn jetzt die ganze Landungssache
doch mal nicht so funktioniert hat,
wie ihr es wollt,
oder ihr schaut zu,
dass ihr vielleicht nicht ganz so gemacht habt,
wie ihr es schön gehabt hättet
und sich dabei verletzt habt,
ist ja wichtig,
dass ihr wisst, wie ihr euch um einen Verletzten kümmert.
Wir haben beim Gleitschirmfliegen
leider einen Nachteil,
dass wir in der sitzenden Position sind,
sprich, wenn wir
oben runter kommen,
haben wir immer die sitzende Position,
es geht ziemlich direkt auf die Wirbelsäule.
Darum sind auch Wirbelsäulenverletzungen
beim Gleitschirmfliegen nicht unüblich
und wenn wir an einen Verletzten hinkommen,
ist es genauso wichtig,
dass wir das auch wissen.
Das heisst, wir müssen grundsätzlich
einmal beruhigen und dann
merkt man relativ schnell,
wie stark oder wo ist der Pilot verletzt.
Ist er wirklich am Rücken verletzt
und ist er am Atmen,
funktioniert alles noch,
ist das Beste, ihn liegen zu lassen
und unmittelbar sofort Rega zu informieren,
dass sie mit einem Helikopter kommen
und ihn abtransportieren können.
Wenn der Helikopter kommt,
muss er wissen, dass er viel Wind macht,
sobald er landet.
Das heisst, er muss den Schirm zusammennehmen,
vielleicht mit einem Verumfalter,
alles einpacken und beschweren
mit Steinen oder Ästen,
damit nichts wegfliegen kann
und der Helikopter auch noch gefährdet.
Verletzungen, wenn sie
auf den Rücken gehen,
ist auch wichtig.
Wenn der Pilot aufsitzen will
oder etwas trinken will,
ist eine normale Reaktion
verhindert.
Man soll liegen bleiben,
nicht bewegen, solange er ansprechbar ist
und dann auch nicht zu trinken geben.
Das ist enorm wichtig,
denn wir wissen nicht, ob er noch innere Verletzungen hat
oder nicht.
Jetzt kommen wir auf das Thema der Flugtechnik.
Es geht darum,
dass wir alle wissen,
was unser Schirm überhaupt kann
oder respektive was wir beeinflussen können,
damit der Schirm
besser gleitet
oder weniger sinkt.
Es ist ganz einfach
auf dieser Skala ersichtlich,
dass wenn wir sagen,
wir wollen bei einem Schulschirm
unser bestes Gleiten herausholen,
d.h. wir kommen von Punkt A
nach Punkt B
am weitesten,
dass wir unsere Bremse
ungefähr auf 5-15 cm Kontakt haben
bei dieser Geschwindigkeit,
die ihr hier lesen könnt.
Wenn wir das Ganze möglichst lange
in der Luft bleiben,
also das geringste Sinken herausholen,
und zwar nicht am weitesten,
sind aber von der Zeit her am längsten in der Luft,
dann müssen wir etwas mehr anbremsen,
nämlich schon 15-10 kmh,
etwas mehr als Trim Speed.
Und wenn wir minimal fahren,
also das, was der Gleitschirm
gleich noch fliegen mag,
bevor er Richtung Sack fliegt,
wo wir später dazu kommen,
sind wir relativ stark angebremst,
da gehen wir schon richtig Hüften runter.
Wichtig, die Ellbogen schauen immer noch schön runter.
Und dann
sind wir etwa bei 40 cm,
wo wir schon relativ im langsamen Bereich fliegen.
Das Gegenteil können wir auch machen,
nämlich beschleunigen.
Wenn wir unseren Fuss beschleunigen,
wie bei den meisten der Fall ist,
können wir durchtreten,
dann holen wir viel Geschwindigkeit wieder hin,
weil wir nichts anderes machen,
als unseren Anstellwinkel zu verkleinern
und wir werden schneller.
Und so fliegt auch der Schirm deutlich schneller.
Den Beschleuniger brauchen wir ganz einfach gesagt
immer dann,
wenn wir Gegenwind haben.
So ist bei ruhiger Luft
natürlich am besten das beste Gleiten.
Wenn wir Rückenwind haben,
ist ein bisschen mehr Anbremse,
am besten das geringste Sinken.
Wenn wir Gegenwind haben,
dann müssen wir beschleunigen.
Ganz einfach
fürs Verständnis,
wir fliegen 30 kmh,
wir haben 30 kmh Gegenwind,
wir würden stehen.
Gott sei Dank können wir beschleunigen,
wenn wir etwa noch mal 10 kmh rausholen können
und dann fliegen wir eben doch noch 10 kmh vorwärts.
Das würde der Vorteil sein,
den Landeplatz oder wo immer wir hinfliegen,
noch zu erreichen können.
Dann gibt es ja nicht nur das Fliegen
an und für sich mit Start und Land,
wie wir es jetzt schon besprochen haben,
sondern es soll ja auch Spass machen.
Es gibt auch das sogenannte Soaring.
Wenn wir die Hangaufwind nutzen können,
dann reden wir eigentlich von Soaring.
Wenn das ein überregionaler Wind ist,
wo der Hang aufströmt,
erzeugt das ein Aufwindband
und in diesem Aufwindband
können wir unsere hohe Palte aussteigern
und das nennt man Soaring.
Das ist meistens nur windbedingt.
Es gibt auch thermisch-dynamische Soaring,
die noch etwas vermischt ist mit Thermik.
Hier reden wir jetzt mal von Soaring.
Dort ist es wichtig,
direkt als Anfänger,
Geländestabstand, Geländestabstand
und nochmal Geländestabstand.
Warum?
Weil wir die ganze Zeit am Gelände sind.
Es gibt vielleicht noch andere Flugteilnehmer,
die auch diese fliegen wollen
und ein bisschen Turbulenzen verursachen
durch ihr Fluggerät.
Es kann schnell mal unruhig werden
oder es kann auch mal etwas mehr Wind geben
und es treibt uns etwas mehr
Richtung Hang, damit wir Zeit haben
zu reagieren, dass wir wieder vom Hang wegfliegen.
Und allgemein
immer die Kurve weg vom Hang drehen.
Nie zum Hang hin.
Hier haben wir
Rückenwindkomponenten.
Wir haben Sinkgründigkeitskomponenten
von der Kurve selber.
Ist nicht abschätzbar.
Und wenn man mit Rückenwind so richtig
fliegt, dann muss man auch
die Sachen, die hier stehen,
beim Soaring immer ganz fest beachten.
Jetzt haben wir je nach Gebiet
natürlich auch das Thermikfliegen drin.
Und das Thermikfliegen ist ja das,
was wahrscheinlich die Königsdisziplin ist
beim Gleitschirmfliegen.
Wir wollen ja möglichst weit fliegen.
Das heisst, wir wollen Thermik nutzen
als Transporter.
Weil wenn wir nur fliegen in der ruhigen Luft,
dann haben wir auch für unsere Gleitleistung,
wenn wir zum Beispiel von 1000 Metern starten,
dann kommen wir 8 Kilometer weit.
Bei ruhiger Luft.
Jetzt haben wir aber Thermik.
Das heisst, dann muss ich auch
Bescheid wissen, wie ich mich
mit der Thermik überhaupt verhalte
und wie ich die auch fliege.
Thermik fliegen. Damit ich Thermik fliegen kann,
muss ich auch ein paar Grundregeln wissen.
Am einfachsten ist natürlich,
wenn wir die visuelle Kontrolle haben
vor einer Wolke, dann sehen wir
die Thermik optisch.
Es ist deutlich einfacher so zu fliegen.
Wir nehmen jetzt das Beispiel der Wolke.
Wenn wir Wind haben, ist es relativ einfach
den Schlauch zu finden.
Dann fliegen wir einfach gerade unter die Wolke
und haben den Schlauch relativ schnell gefunden.
Hoffentlich können wir steigen.
Das Ganze wird etwas schwieriger, wenn wir Wind haben.
Wir nehmen jetzt hier das Beispiel,
dass der Wind von links kommt.
Die Wolke wird also so abgetrieben.
Das heisst, mit dem Schirm muss ich jetzt
in die Laufseite der Wolke fliegen,
damit ich schön im Schlauch
mit dem Windversatz zusammen steigen kann
und so optimal Thermik verwitschen kann.
Das Ganze,
ist relativ einfach im Flachland aussen,
auch gut zum Üben.
Schwieriger wird es, wenn wir dann
Richtung Berge gehen,
Richtung einen Berg, der eine Steilwand hat.
Dort ist die Thermik sehr knackig,
löst sehr schnell ab.
Das heisst, sie ist nicht grossflächig,
sondern kleinflächig und dementsprechend
auch eher turbulent.
Das ist zwar gut, wenn man sehr schnell
sehr eng will kreisen und steigen,
aber für einen Anfänger fehlt das sehr rasch
zur Überforderung.
Damit man schön locker sitzt,
dass man viel mit Gewichtsverlagerung arbeitet.
Man dreht einerseits die Thermik
schön aus,
aber auch ganz fest mit dem Gewicht arbeiten.
Viele Piloten machen das viel zu wenig,
dann fest über die Bremse arbeiten
und zu wenig mit Gewichtsverlagerung.
Ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Wichtig ist auch, dass man die Thermik
den Aufwind dann verlässt,
wenn man sicher ist, dass man den nächsten Punkt,
den man vorgängig bestimmen wollte,
auch erreicht.
Und dass man zu früh losgeht
und dann gar nicht am nächsten Berg
ins Flachland kommt, wo man die nächste Thermik erwartet.
Sondern es ist wirklich wichtig,
dass man die Thermik ausdreht.
Und einem braucht das viel Geduld,
dass man die Höhe dann hat,
dass man sicher zu dem nächsten Planterpunkt
ankommt, wo man davon ausgeht,
dass die nächste Thermik wieder stattfindet,
wieder einen nach oben befördert.
Das Ganze braucht natürlich extrem viel Erfahrung
und am Anfang zufrieden sein,
wenn man mal im Flachland eine Thermik drehen kann,
schön gemütlich steigen hat,
das kann man geniessen.
Da kommt auch der Erfolg mit der Erfahrung.
Beim Thermikfliegen kommen wir auch
irgendwann zu Situationen,
die man vielleicht nicht unbedingt will,
sprich unser Schirm fliegt dann mal so,
wie wir es nicht gewohnt sind.
Da gehören die Seitenklappen dazu,
da gehören vielleicht die Frontklappen dazu.
Was wir jetzt in diesem Thema
durchnehmen,
Entschuldigung,
durchnehmen, ist die Flugmanöver.
Wenn ihr beim Schweizerischen Hängegleiterverband
auf die Homepage geht,
hat man auch die Prüfungsmanöver,
relevante Manöver,
wunderschön als Video erklärt,
weil auch an der Prüfung
muss man gewisse Manöver von diesen
fliegen können.
Wir fangen an bei den kleinen Ohren,
das haben wir vorhin schon mal gehört bei der Landung.
Kleine Ohren sind nichts anderes,
als die äussersten Anleinen von jedem Schirm,
es ist die äusserste Anleine,
nicht zu verwechseln mit der Stabilo-Leine.
Die Stabilo-Leine ist die,
die auf den äussersten Punkt des Gleitschirms
trennt und sehr dünn.
Wir haben aber die äusserste Anleine,
die wir auch brauchen, um den Schirm aufzuziehen,
die ist zum Teil bei gewissen Gleitschirmmodellen
trennt, zum Teil auch zusammen,
es ist einfach immer die äusserste.
Wir gehen links und rechts hoch,
und dann unsere kleinen Ohren einklappen.
Wir behalten die unten und können wunderbar
eben mit Gewichtsverlagerung
den Schirm trotzdem noch steuern.
Die kleinen Ohren sind, wie schon gesagt,
z.B. wenn wir eine hohe Landung haben
und es etwas schneller runter geht,
super Manöver.
Dann können wir auch etwas mehr Sinken generieren,
um den Schirm kennen zu lernen,
um kleine Ohren zu machen.
Das ist ein absolut gutes Manöver.
Es gibt auch grosse Ohren,
dann nimmt man je nach Schirmmodell
nicht nur die äusserste Anleine,
sondern auch die zweitäusserste,
wenn wir drei haben.
Dann kommen viel mehr Ohren rein.
Ganz wichtig dort,
es gibt auch Schirme, die nur zwei Aufhänkungen haben,
da dürfen wir nicht beide rein,
sonst machen wir gleich einen Frontklapper.
Dann gehen wir nichts anderes,
als die Ohren zu greifen
und für grosse Ohren
nehmen wir einfach unsere Hand von innen her
und dann abknicken.
Dadurch holen wir rund 15-20 cm mehr Leinen runter
und nehmen sie dann rein für grosse Ohren.
Ganz wichtig bei den grossen Ohren,
gleichzeitig zu diesem Prozess
von der Leine reinholen,
beschleunigen.
Nur so können wir verhindern,
dass wir zu viele Ohren machen,
zu viel Widerstand und der Schirm zu langsam fliegt
und dann Richtung Sackflug geht.
Indem wir das beschleunigen, dann drücken,
holen wir hier vorne die Eintrittskante wieder runter
und der Schirm fliegt wieder
im normalen Winkel,
trotz dem grossen Widerstand,
den die Ohren machen.
Dann, um die Ohren aufzumachen,
einfach loslassen, erst wenn die Ohren
komplett offen sind,
dann aus dem Beschleuniger rausgehen.
Auch hier würden wir die Ohren drin haben,
lassen sie los und gehen gleich aus dem Beschleuniger raus.
Dann haben wir immer noch viel Widerstand
und der Schirm fliegt langsam
und wenn wir durch den Beschleuniger rausgehen,
kann es sein, dass wir dann
gleich Richtung Sackflug-Tendenz kommen
und das wollen wir verhindern.
Sackflug ist ja nichts anderes als
wir zu langsam fliegen.
Unser Schirm sollte fliegen, sollte Vorwärtsfahrt haben,
jetzt haben wir das mal unterschritten.
Dann gibt es, bevor er quasi
nach hinten kippt und komplett
die Luft entleert aus dem Schirm,
gibt es eine Vorstufe des Sackflugs.
Der Schirm ist zwar noch gefüllt,
wir haben aber keine Vorwärtsfahrt mehr
und wir haben nur noch sinken
und es fühlt sich komisch an.
Der Schirm ist oben schwammig.
Dann sind wir zu langsam geflogen,
haben die Bremse zu weit runter.
Oder bei ganz nassem Schirm geflogen.
Kann auch sein, dass man dann
in einen Sackflug kommt.
Dann ist es grundsätzlich wichtig,
wir sind zu langsam geflogen.
Was ist das Gegenteil von langsam?
Schnell, also wenn wir schnell werden.
Das heisst, sofort die Hände an die A-Traggurte
und drücken, damit ihr Speed macht.
Oder auch beschleunigen,
wie es der Wort zeigt.
Wenn wir die Hände beschleunigen,
kriegen wir den Schirm wieder in die normale Position.
Damit er wieder Fahrt aufnimmt
und wir aus dem Sackflug rauskommen.
Was auch gleich im Thermik fliegen geht,
dass wir mal fliegen
und wir vermutschen eine Windschärung
und BÄCK, der Schirm ist 50% drin.
Völlig aus dem Nichts raus.
Verschrecken wir zuerst einmal,
ist normal am Anfang,
aber auch hier ist es wichtig,
dass wir reagieren können und müssen reagieren.
Wenn wir nichts machen,
macht der Schirm nach dem Klappen wieder extrem viel Widerstand.
Wir haben hier noch einen Hang,
da kommt es relativ schnell nicht gut.
Darum ist es wichtig,
dass wir sofort reagieren.
Der Klapper drinnen oder draussen ist egal.
Wenn der Klapper passiert,
muss unser Grundsatz sein,
sofort Gewicht auf die Gegenseite,
leicht anbremsen mit der Gegenbremse,
wenn es nötig ist,
damit wir mal geradeaus fliegen können.
Hier gilt wieder der Grundsatz,
zuerst stabilisieren und dann reagieren.
Dann können wir uns um den Klapper beschäftigen
und ihn wieder öffnen.
Wenn wir Absteighilfe machen wollen,
also etwas schneller runter kommen,
weil wir zum Beispiel
das Gewitter im Anmarsch haben
und wir sagen,
wir wollen nicht so lange in der Luft sein,
bevor das Gewitter bei uns ist,
dann kann es sein,
dass es Sinn macht, gewisse Absteigmanöver zu beherrschen.
Die grossen Ohren,
die wir vorhin besprochen haben,
das ist ein ganz wichtiges und gutes Absteigmanöver,
denn mit den grossen Ohren
kann man mit dem Gewicht noch steuern
und wenn wir in einem starken Aufwindband sind,
fliegen wir weg von diesem Aufwindband
und bleiben nicht noch drinnen.
Der Pestal, der hier auch beschrieben wird
und an den Briefen gefragt wird,
der hat den grossen Nachteil,
dass wir diesen zwar machen können
und relativ viele Sinken generieren,
wir aber an Ort und Stelle runter kommen,
sprich, wenn wir im Aufwindband sind,
im starken, immer noch drinnen sind
und eigentlich wollen wir ja wegfliegen.
Pestal ist nichts anderes,
als, wie der Name sagt,
die Betragsgurten gehen,
die Betragsgurten langsam zu uns hinziehen.
Wichtig ist dabei,
dass wir die Bremse ganz normal in den Händen haben,
nicht irgendwie gewickelt,
damit wir sie gleichzeitig auch noch runterziehen,
sondern dass wir den Pestal so runterziehen.
Und dann gibt es hier im Untersägel einen Falz
und ich merke,
die haben nur noch Sinken
und da kann man gut ein paar Sekunden behalten
bei einem Training
oder auch unter Begleitung
des Fluglehrers am Funk
kann man das gut mal üben.
Der Pestal wieder lösen ist nichts anderes,
als den Anfangsbereich langsam
und dann ganz hoch zu führen
und hier auch wieder für gewisse
fliegende Schemen,
es ist nicht wirklich eine Sackflug-Tendenz,
allenfalls die Betragsgurten nach vorne drücken,
damit er wieder schneller fliegt.
Eine Steilspirale ist so ein Thema für sich.
Das ist etwas,
das man vor allem unter Begleitung lernen sollte
oder an einem Sicherheitstraining.
Ich werde es aber ganz schnell anschneiden.
Steilspirale ist nichts anderes,
als eine Bremse,
ein relativ fest ziehendes Gewicht
voll auf die Seite,
der Schirm geht so in eine Kurve hinein,
wird immer schneller, schneller, schneller
und beginnt sich dann so wie vom Himmel abzuschrauben.
Das Ganze ist relativ schnell
und braucht auch Training,
um sauber wieder rauszukommen.
Darum sollte man das nur unter Anleitung lernen
und sich bewusst sein,
dass G-Kräfte,
also die Kräfte auf einem wirken,
sehr schnell mehr werden,
als man gewohnt ist.
Jetzt haben wir unser Gewicht in 100 Kilo.
Jetzt gehen wir in eine starke Steilspirale.
Kann das vielleicht auf 4G hochgehen?
Dann wirken auf unseren Körper schon 400 Kilo.
Und das verträgt nicht jeder.
Darum ist es wichtig,
ein sauberes Training zu machen
an einem Sicherheitskurs unter Anleitung.
Oder es gibt auch die Chance
vom G-Force Trainer,
wo du das wunderbar an einem Simulator
üben und dich kennenlernen kannst,
wie du reagierst bei Steilspiralen-Geschichten.
Ein neues Manöver,
das kommt jetzt in der Theorie-Frage nicht,
aber ganz schnell zu erwähnen,
ist, dass man eine Steilspirale macht
mit einem Klappenkalt.
Zuerst macht man eine Seitenklappe,
die wir schon besprochen haben,
und dann macht man auf der Gegenseite,
die offen ist, noch eine Spirale.
Das hat den Vorteil,
dass man viel Sinken generiert,
aber wenig G-Kräfte hat.
Das ist immer wieder eine G-Kräfte,
die eine Gefahr darstellen kann.
Das ist auch ein Manöver,
der ein Sequel gehört,
mit einem Twist, Wing-Over und Nicken.
Ihr müsst wissen, was das ist.
Frillen ist nichts anderes,
als dass wir eine Seite zu viel runterziehen,
z.B. haben wir eine Spirale
landen wollen,
haben es aber völlig grobmotorisch gemacht
und dann geht die eine Seite weg
und der Schirm dreht negativ.
Das ist ein Frillen.
Wenn wir das sehr schnell machen,
kann es sein, dass der Schirm oben dreht
und wir unten haben ein Momentum,
wo wir dem Schirm zuerst mit dem Folgen
zu wenig schnell sind.
Wir befinden uns aber immer noch
in dieser Position vom Anfang.
Dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
hier sind unsere Traggurten,
ganz schnell macht der Schirm etwas zurück
und jetzt habe ich einen Twist.
Das heisst nichts anderes,
als dass die Traggurte gekreuzt sind.
Dann bin ich im Twist.
Das ist der Begriff dafür.
Wenn ich Wing-Over fliegen will,
ist es nichts anderes,
dass ich den Schirm zur Rolle bringe.
Das heisst, ich entscheide mich
für eine Seite, links oder rechts,
und sobald ich wieder unten reingehe,
gebe ich bereits auf die Gegenseite
den Bremsimpuls und das Gewicht.
Paff!
Immer Gewicht vor Bremsimpuls.
Und dann gibt es sogenannte Wing-Overs.
Das ist ein Spassmanöver,
das wir auch
an der Praxisprüfung zeigen müssen.
Es kann sein, dass das vorkommt.
Dort werden sie sehen,
dass ihr die Wing-Over auf Stabilohöhe
jeweils hinbringt.
Das heisst Rollen.
Das ist nichts anderes als Wing-Over.
Und es macht Spass.
Es ist ein gutes Manöver,
um den Schirm zu kennenlernen und zu trainieren.
Das gleiche Snicken.
Snicken ist nichts anderes,
als den Schirm stark anzubremsen.
Der Schirm geht nach hinten.
Wir als Person nach vorne.
Und jetzt warten wir,
bis der Schirm wieder nach vorne kommt
und vorschiesst.
Warten, bis wir unten durch pendeln.
Jetzt wollen wir wieder bremsen.
Wir müssen wirklich warten,
bis wir am untersten Punkt drüber sind
und dann wieder bremsen,
damit wir eine Knickbewegung bekommen.
Auch dort werden sie an der Prüfung sehen,
dass ihr bis zur Austrittskante
und Eintrittskante pendelt.
Das ist nicht ein wahnsinnig starkes Knicken,
aber wir müssen es am Schirm schaffen.
Das ist das Ziel,
dass wir das Ganze kennenlernen.
Jetzt den Frilletwist-Manöver
wie Wing-Over und Knicken.
Das kann alles viel Spass machen
und macht absolut Sinn.
Zum Trainieren.
Jetzt kann es aber auch sein,
dass das Ganze in die Hose geht.
Und dann das Thema
Rettungssystem,
das im nächsten Kapitel zum Zug kommt.
Ihr müsst euch bewusst sein,
euer Rettungssystem
nützt nichts.
Das ist absolut für die Katze,
euer Rettungssystem.
Wenn ihr es nicht zieht.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Grundsatz.
Die Faschenspringer haben ein System,
bei dem wenn sie eine gewisse Höhe beschritten haben,
automatisch in ein System
die Rettung ziehen.
Wir Gleitschirmflieger haben das nicht.
Und konstruktionsbedingt hat es auch noch niemand
geschafft eine Lösung dafür zu finden.
Das heisst, in einer Notsituation
müssen wir als Pilot aktiv
den Notschirm ziehen.
Und nur wenn wir ihn ziehen,
funktioniert er auch.
Da müssen wir uns ganz fest im Bewusstsein sein.
Wenn wir eine Situation haben,
out of control,
wird sich diese Situation nicht verbessern.
Sie verbessert sich erst dann,
wenn wir sagen,
jetzt ist es nicht mehr gut,
jetzt habe ich out of control,
jetzt muss ich meinen Schirm ziehen.
Wenn ich ihn ziehe,
der Grundsatz ist immer dann,
wenn es unkontrollierbar ist.
Sprich, ich habe einen Zustand,
den ich nicht mehr weiss,
wo oben, wo unten ist.
Und dieser Zustand stabilisiert sich
nicht innerhalb der verkürzten Zeit,
da reden wir 2-3 Sekunden,
das ist Zeit für den Notschirm.
Habe ich das Ganze wenig Höhe,
sprich, ich war beim Abbauraum im Landebereich
und ich habe eh schon wenig Höhe
und ich habe ein Problem,
sofort den Notschirm ziehen.
Out of control,
ich weiss nicht mehr, was der Schirm macht,
sofort den Notschirm ziehen.
Das kann aus einer Klappe heraus passieren,
es kann passieren, dass Sie zu fest gebremst haben,
wie wir vorhin gesehen haben,
eine Frille passiert, etwas Unkontrolliertes,
gleich Notschirm.
Das kann aber auch sein,
wir haben zwar relativ viel Platz in der Luft,
aber doch andere Luftfahrtteilnehmer
und wenn wir einen Zusammenstoss haben,
dann ist es sicher auch Zeit,
für den Notschirm zu ziehen.
Wir wissen nämlich selbst,
wenn wir den Zusammenstoss hatten
und wieder fliegen,
wissen wir nicht,
ist unser Fluggerät so stark beschädigt,
dass wir vielleicht genau dann erst merken,
wenn wir im Landeanflug sind,
sprich nicht mehr reagieren können
und den Notschirm ziehen.
Es kann auch sein,
dass Sie über ein grosses Feld fliegen,
den Notschirm ziehen,
wenn Sie eh schon out of control sind,
kommt wieder das erste zum Grundsatz,
Satz zum Einbedenken
und den Notschirm sofort ziehen.
Es kann auch sein,
dass Sie ein medizinisches Problem haben,
Sie fliegen raus und es würde schwarz vor Augen,
irgendetwas war nicht okay,
dann ist der Notschirm die beste Variante,
irgendwo ohnmächtig ins Gelände zu fliegen
mit dem Gleitschirm keine gute Option.
Was heutzutage sehr wenig vorkommt,
bis gar nicht mehr vorkommt,
ist Materialbruch,
aber es könnte ja mal sein,
dass es eben doch vorkommt.
Ihr merkt hier am Gurtzeug ist etwas,
wie es nicht mehr sollte
und ihr habt eine Flugbahn durch das,
was ihr kaum halten könnt,
weil ihr schräg im Gurtzeug sitzt,
weil etwas gerissen ist,
dann ist es sicher auch ein Thema für den Notschirm.
Der Grundsatz der zweiten Chance,
wie immer unkontrolliert ist,
dass der Notschirm nützlich ist,
ist ganz, ganz wichtig für die ganze Flugerei.
Ich sage bewusst zweite Chance,
wenn wir diese haben
und müssen wissen,
wie funktioniert das ganze System.
Wie das funktioniert,
müsst ihr unbedingt bei eurer Flugschule
nachfragen.
Ihr müsst das trainieren in der Jury,
dass ihr wisst, wo der Notschirmgriff ist.
Eine gute Übung dazu ist zum Beispiel auch,
wenn ihr mit einem Normalflug ausfliegt,
mit der flachen Hand,
bei jedem Flug,
wo der Notschirm ist,
dass ihr im Notfall dann auch wisst,
wie zu reagieren.
Der Notschirm ist ein grosser Bereich,
da gehören noch Sachen dazu,
wie viel man packen muss.
Dass zum Beispiel die Hersteller sagen,
alle sechs Monate frisch packen.
Die Praxis zeigt so ein wenig
sechs Monate bis in ein Jahr.
Alles andere sollte man dann wirklich nicht machen,
länger als ein Jahr verpackt,
sondern gehört neu gefaltet.
Das ist ein grosses Thema
und ein Kurs,
für sich allein.
Was wir hier besprochen haben,
die Flugpraxis,
das ist das,
was an der Prüfung gefragt wird.
Ihr müsst es kennen.
Ich hoffe, euch hat dieser Vortrag gefallen.
Ich bedanke mich ganz fest
für eure Aufmerksamkeit
und bis bald in der Luft.